hey you guys movie retrospective time so
this was the movie once again that uh
won the poll on patreon and it's
actually kind of good that we're doing
this one around this time of year
because it's kind of like a Halloweeny
kind of movie I guess not technically
but I mean it's kind of like New England
and it seems like it's witches and stuff
like that so yeah this is The Witches of
Eastwick from 1987. damn now yeah now
you would never seen this right I had
seen this probably like a hundred times
I think I saw this in the theater when
it came out and then I remember like
really liking it and then like I saw it
a bunch more times on cable I might have
also had it on VHS at some point
um but I hadn't seen it for a really
long time so I was like really
interested to watch it again I also read
the novel by John Updike now
interestingly I watched I saw the movie
before I read the novel and actually I
liked the movie so I was like oh I'll
read the book the book is a lot
different different like the first part
of it is the same but I kind of want to
get into that a little bit too but the
book was like a lot darker and it has
kind of like another subplot that they
completely like took out of the movie so
like the end of the movie so the movie
and book are like not really all that
similar like they're tonally kind of
different sounds like I would have liked
the book
um I didn't like the book so I didn't
really like it not not us not because it
wasn't like the movie it's just I don't
know I kind of feel like in the book
um The Witches like the women were a lot
more obviously malevolent
um like they did some kind of more
[ __ ] up [ __ ] than they did in the
movie and Daryl Van Horn like the devil
character that Jack Nicholson plays in
the movie was also a lot more obviously
malevolent whereas like in the movie
it's a lot more subtle and like they do
bad [ __ ] but it's kind of more played
for Laughs a little bit you know what I
mean whereas in the book the book was
kind of like satirical and funny a
little bit too but but it was kind of
more I don't know if I'd necessarily
call it a horror story but
I don't know but it just like had more
because like for example in the book and
this is absolutely not even referred to
in the movie in the book
um you know the he hooks up with the
three women and everything like that but
then later on he actually marries this
really really young woman who was
actually like the daughter of uh you
know the Felicia character who uh
Veronica Cartwright plays in the movie
so he marries her and the other three
women get jealous and do a spell on her
and give her cancer and kill her and
then after that like at the end and like
the witches don't get pregnant in the
book
um Daryl Van Horn just leaves like at
the end of the book with uh Jenny's
Jenny is the name of the woman that like
the young woman that he marries and he
runs off with Jenny's brother and it's
insinuated that they're that they're
lovers now like him and the brother and
he just like leaves town so all of the
stuff that happens in the movie with
like the women like getting revenge and
all that other kind of stuff that
doesn't happen in the book he just like
takes off at the end it's at least what
I remember because that's not the same
story it's not really I mean the first
like half of it is but once um he
marries that other girl like it just it
goes in like two Divergent completely
different Divergent directions but other
the setup is the same though and like
some of the characters and stuff are the
same so I had forgotten too that this
was directed by George [ __ ]
Miller who you know Mad Max he did Mad
Max he had Fury Road he does I mean he
did others to like family films and
stuff too like he did Babe like the the
pig movie which is actually like really
really good like for a family film I
think this was kind of his first big
Hollywood movie yeah that's that's the
thing about this movie all right
the acting is good man Jack Nicholson
does a good job as the devil in it it's
got some really good strong points in it
but there's something about the tone of
this movie
it's very kind of late 80s Yuppie
feeling kind of like wolf remember the
they had the down yeah they kind of had
a damn Jack Nicholson being a damn
werewolf and Michelle Pfeiffer was
myself and she's also with me she's in
this and it's kind of an elevated movie
for the older crowd you know I mean it
it just kind of has that tone that that
The Witches of Eastwick was for a boomer
a boomer Yuppie population that that's
who they were targeted at or at least it
was supposed to be kind of targeted to
them it might have been a faux Target I
don't know like we're gonna make a movie
it's gonna be kayak yeah I kind of felt
like it was targeted toward that but the
weird thing about it was that you know
uh girls in particular and even some
guys that were my age like in 1987 so
when I was like a teenager a lot of them
really dug it even though technically
yeah like the story is kind of more
targeted toward an older audience
because the witches like the the women
are middle-aged you know what I mean and
they've all gotten to a point in their
lives where you know one of them their
husband died one of them their husband
deserted them one of them they got
divorced and then like so they're kind
of like coming into their own like now
that they're men in their life are gone
and now now that they're like free or
whatever so it's almost kind of like a
Stella Got Her Groove Back kind of
situation but I don't know why
like people my age because I was
watching some other
um reviews of this and some other
reviewers like female reviewers that
were my age were talking about how much
they [ __ ] loved this movie even
though they were teenagers like same age
as me like when this came out even
though maybe we couldn't relate to some
aspects of it I kind of feel like I
didn't even like I got that I'm not dumb
but it's like I got that whole you know
oh they're middle aged and they're like
embarking on a new finding their their
power their own personality or whatever
like after all of these time and it's
like I got that but it's just kind of
like I guess I couldn't really relate to
it in the way that I maybe could relate
to it now yeah Jack Nicholson as the
devil his one of his main weapons is uh
uh [ __ ] I guess probably like third
wave feminism he's using uh like a lot
of feminist philosophy and then he
creates these three feminist witches
that end up [ __ ] him over in the end
well the thing about it is that when he
comes there here's the thing like he
comes there and he he knows I mean if
you don't know the story of Witches of
Eastwick it's Jack Nicholson and he
plays the devil they never call on the
devil uh they hint that he's the devil
and he clearly probably is but he plays
a character named Daryl Van Horn and he
comes to the town and he seduces three
of the women but see he needs them he
needs them to reproduce because that's
the one thing that he can't do is have a
baby so he approaches each of these
three women in turn but he approaches
them exactly in the way that he knows
will work on them you know what I'm
saying so if they you know want to hear
like a particular thing like you said
like third wave feminism or whatever
that's what he's gonna say because he's
manipulating them essentially he wants
them to have his babies so he's seducing
each one of them like in a different way
and the way that's most effective for
them yeah when he goes after share he
just uses the [ __ ] path
I just want to [ __ ] you remember that in
that word somehow well not so much [ __ ]
but he's he's like um oh he's a [ __ ]
well no I mean he the way that he put it
was that um you know I I don't want to
insult your intelligence by like trying
to seduce you I just want to be blunt
and honest and at first that doesn't
work because like honestly one of my
favorite exchanges in the movie is when
he first tries tries to seduce Cher and
he's like kind of like laying on the bed
and he's obviously like Jack Nicholson
at this point in his life not a sexy man
uh really he was kind of sexy when he
was younger he's very charismatic I'm
not saying that but not like physically
attractive or not like physically sexy
she tells him and she yeah and she just
basically goes on this big long rant
it's like
intellectually [ __ ] stupid and you
smell you know what I mean and I was
just kind of like that was like and he's
just like sitting there like listening
to all of this big long [ __ ] uh Brian
acts that she reads him and it's just
like so so funny but then I I think that
he tried that first attack with her and
he's like that didn't work so then he
comes at her from a different angle like
she starts to leave and then he's like
oh where are you going you know you
don't nobody needs you anymore like you
have a kid but she's old enough to take
care of herself now it's like you know
what do you have to go back to you know
what I mean there's nobody that depends
on you and like you know everybody
thinks you're useless and all this other
kind of stuff and that kind of like gets
to her because you know that's what she
was thinking about herself you know what
I mean like I feel like the other two
were probably easier because
um like Susan Sarandon's character Jane
who is like super super like
conservative of like very very buttoned
up and uh house mouse yeah and like she
like her husband left her just because
she couldn't have babies she said
because they thought that she was a
Barren as they used to say
um but she's a musician and so he comes
at her from that angle where he's like a
really good musician but he like try
eyes to get like all the passion out of
her which the thing about this movie
that's kind of great is that yes he's
the devil and yes like bad [ __ ] ends up
happening but he does like help them you
know what I mean like he does kind of
help them
find their own power which I don't know
was necessarily his intention you know I
don't know no I think he did he
developed him
I mean mostly I don't even know maybe
that was just like a side effect mostly
he just wanted the babies he wanted uh
Offspring yeah I kind of think it was a
trade though it yeah it very well made
he was gonna get he was going to get him
knocked up but they were gonna they were
gonna uh be willing and the only way
they were going to be willing is he
Charmed the hell out of him and uh
develop and fulfill them basically which
is kind of what he did
so it was a it was a trade it was a
relationship but then he then he also
made but again I don't know
he got mad and they dumped him and well
and two because I think that's why they
set this like in such a small uh you
know very kind of like very uptight town
uh I think it's supposed to be Rhode
Island at least that's what it was in
the book I thought it was Connecticut
for some reason but it's not it's
supposed to be Rhode Island but it's
supposed to be like this really really
like tight-knit community and like when
the three of them start going up there
and like all having you know uh a little
uh relationship there all for him yeah
um when they start doing that like uh
all of the all of the rumors like around
town start like getting to them where
you know Susan Sarandon is in the store
with her frizz out hair and she's like
all sexy now and all this other kind of
stuff and everybody's just calling her a
[ __ ] and all this other kind of stuff
then they can't really deal with it and
I think when they when they dump him it
wasn't that they didn't like that
because at first they were like well I
don't really like having to go around
town and getting called a [ __ ] all the
time because of all the [ __ ] we're doing
up here but they actually were they
talked about like not seeing each other
after that but then I think what was the
real Catalyst for that was when Felicia
got killed now Felicia Veronica
Cartwright is in this like who plays
Felicia who it this is never explicitly
stated but I always thought in the movie
that she was like the fourth witch but
she's like one that's on the opposite
side of them like they didn't know they
were witches and neither does she you
know what I mean it kind of took them
because at the beginning of the movie
like the three of them they're just
talking about oh we were just talking we
were all thinking that we wanted it to
rain and that it did rain and then they
start talking about their ideal man and
they kind of conjure him or like draw
him to the town and as the movie goes on
they realize that they have more power
than they knew about so they didn't go
out like set out to be witches but the
thing about
um Felicia like Veronica Cartwright's
character is I think she is also a witch
but because she's like super super
religious
um she doesn't really see her powers
that way I guess she thinks that it
comes from Jesus or whatever
um but she's like the only one that as
soon as Jack Nicholson comes into town
she's immediately like I you know we're
not having it there's something wrong
with him and
you know she doesn't like that he's
buying the house but she's pretty
cognizant that there's something else
that matter with him too and I think
even later on she does that she says
that he's the devil
but the funny thing is that early on in
the movie she falls down the stairs and
breaks her leg and then the doctor tells
her husband oh well sometimes if you
break a bone like bits of the bone
marrow like drift around in your
bloodstream and like open your brain and
like make you say crazy [ __ ] which I
don't know if that's true or not if any
of you like I've never heard that
um but uh but you know it's whatever it
makes sense but in context of the movie
so they don't know if she's just saying
crazy [ __ ] because of the leg being
broken or if she's like actually uh you
know she's actually like on to something
but I think she actually has the same
kind of like witch powers that they have
she's just like kind of at it from a
different direction but the [ __ ] that
happens to her like she gets so
that one scene of her in the church
where she's just sitting there and the
the priest is up there like giving the
you know whatever and she's just sitting
there going horse yes horse it's like
it's so [ __ ] funny yeah that
character was kind of a good character
but I don't know why she was in the
movie I really didn't really know the
significance of it was she the fourth
witch that never yeah spelled it out
well I think that was implied I think
that was important it's almost like she
was on the other end of this she was
also a witch but at the other end of the
spectrum Spectrum as the other three I
think they should have defined that and
cleared that what I'm not really sure
what purpose she served in the story
because she never really met and met the
other witches face to face did she I
don't know not really she was almost
kind of like I kind of saw her as like
the maybe Cassandra character or she was
kind of like the harbinger because as
soon as he moved to town like before
they even show Jack Nicholson where
everyone's like talking about him like
because they do this build up where you
know they're like oh he bought that
house and button everybody's like
talking about him a bit like it's weird
because nobody can like remember his
name and they talk about like how
Charming he is and everything like that
before they even show him but she's like
the only one from the jump that is like
this is bad he shouldn't be coming here
so it's almost like she's the one that
but nobody listens to her so I think she
was kind of like the Cassandra character
maybe yeah but I definitely think that
she was also had the same like Powers I
don't think I don't think I don't think
the concept of her of her character was
really developed well enough
I don't know why it was necessary to
even have her in there I mean it did pad
the movie out so it showed some stuff
happening outside that little quartet
you know the little Harem that he had
going I guess she was just a mechanism
to show the town
you know what I mean well you could see
what was happening in the town I mean I
don't really know and also her death
um is the Catalyst for the other three
witches refusing to see him anymore okay
because she dies
because they thought they were helping
him kill her
no they didn't know I didn't know but
see that's the whole thing like Jack
Nicholson's character he's kind of like
coming at them in the guise of you know
I'm helping develop your womanly
abilities or whatever because
everybody's like holding you down but
then on the same at the same time he's
also manipulating them into doing [ __ ] I
mean he knew what he was doing he knew
like when he had all of them together
and they were talking about how what a
[ __ ] Felicia was and he's like have
another Cherry like they didn't know
what they were doing they only realized
it after that happened like after her
husband had beaten her to death it was
that whole like Cherry pit vomiting
scene and all of that kind of stuff and
then her husband beat her to death and
then they realized holy [ __ ] we did that
why did the husband beat her to death
because he just couldn't take it anymore
he couldn't take it so why did the girls
think that they had something to do with
it they did
they did well they just made her spit up
some
pits I just don't think I just don't
think it's what it was well done you
know what I mean just I just think
that's hokey
um if they were basically just playing a
prank on or they you know they didn't
kill her on purpose
no but they felt bad enough that because
I think prior to that like they kind of
knew it's like oh neat we have these
like little like powers and we can make
stuff happen and I think they kind of
maybe sort of knew that but like then
when it got to that extreme they were
like holy [ __ ] we can actually like kill
people or kind of be indirectly
responsible for their death and so they
[ __ ] what was the problem they didn't
well they didn't really want to be
involved in that you know what I mean
because they didn't know they were
witches before so it's almost like too
much of their power got Unleashed and
they got scared I agree with the devil
you take three women who are middle aged
and been neglected and you turn them
into Super women that they could fly
have incredible sex and [ __ ] and have
children and then they live in this
[ __ ] gigantic Mansion they'll kill to
keep that position because that woman
was a threat to them
yeah all right but I'm just saying they
didn't intentionally yeah it might have
been more intentional in the book maybe
I can't remember I don't remember if
they intentionally killed Felicia in the
book or if they were more aware of what
they were doing now in the book they
absolutely did Kill uh his wife yeah uh
you know Daryl's wife they absolutely
did do that on purpose but I think that
that happened after they figured out oh
like we can indirectly like cause
someone's death and so then they did it
on purpose you know what I mean witches
kill people and do [ __ ] just by right of
nature as soon as you're a witch and
have [ __ ] magical abilities you're
gonna kill people that's what you are
that's what you do so I think I think
that part of the story was kind of
[ __ ] hokey I mean they're already
with the Devil
and they must know that he's the devil
see I don't know I don't know give it a
supernatural power I know I don't know
if they really
I don't know because like I said I
always kind of think about now if this
happened in real life obviously it's not
gonna happen in real life yeah but if it
happened in real life just just you know
theoretically
um I don't know I kind of feel like
maybe you would see all the positives of
it obviously but I you would like think
to yourself he's not the devil come on
well they knew it was the devil when he
was 30 feet tall running around the
outside of the [ __ ] yeah but that was
at the end though that was at the end
after they had kind of got they'd
figured that out and they said oh my God
he knocked all of us up and that's what
he wanted the whole time was like he
wanted them to have babies so he could
propagate his little demon seed or
whatever his his yeah and he had good
looking kids
the uh his his uh his Pad was badass it
was yeah it's just like William Randolph
Hearst [ __ ] couldn't afford a place
like that you know it was just a giant
[ __ ] Stone Mansion you know look nice
something that an old oligarch from the
1800s would have he was yeah I can't
remember like where where they shot the
exteriors of that because that's a real
house I'm pretty sure that's a real
estate because I've seen it in other
movies yeah handmade moral floors and
stuff is beautiful but I'm not sure
where they shot the Interiors of that
because yeah man that house was [ __ ]
badass yeah so he had badge the size of
this room
he said it that way that was like one of
the funniest I kind of feel like when I
saw this when I was younger I think a
lot of the stuff like I didn't really
like I didn't register as much because a
lot of the humor in it and stuff is more
I guess like adult oriented or it's like
kind of more subtle I feel like I don't
know this is where one of those movies
and
I think I was talking about this in a
video that I posted earlier today
or uh earlier this week about uh time
after time is that in the 70s and 80s
you had these kind of movies that you
couldn't really put your finger on what
genre they were you know what I mean
this movie is one of those yeah if you
had to tell me that it's like if you
asked me like put a gun in my head and
said what genre is this I would not be
able to tell you like it's not a horror
movie
really even though it has kind of
horrorary elements toward the end it's
sort of a comedy sort of a romance it's
sort of a romance it's sort of a fantasy
there's like pieces of everything and
it's sort of a chick flick yes sort of
sort of but it's like there's other
stuff going on in there too it's not
like a traditional standard chick flick
because there's like Witchcraft and then
there's like [ __ ] up [ __ ] happens in
it like I said some like
um you know Felicia's husband like beats
her to death with a fireplace poker and
they're then there's like gross [ __ ]
like you know throwing up cherry pits
all over and actually uh Jack Nicholson
does that too at the end just like
throws up [ __ ] cherry juice and [ __ ]
like that over everybody in the church
and he kind of gets all like monstery
toward the end they do like voodoo on
him like make like a wax doll like to
get rid of them and stuff so the closest
thing to it would be wolf
yeah so I kind yeah I feel like and that
came out the same way yeah that's the
same way where it's kind of like kind of
like a love story and kind of funny but
then but also like with horror elements
and I feel like that kind of like a rich
people movie yeah well yeah like a kind
of like a yuppie sort of movie which
this one kind of is too and I just feel
like you don't I don't know it's like
it's so weird you don't really see
movies like that anymore that are just
kind of these like you're not really
sure exactly what to call them you know
what I mean because they're not they
just have aspects of so many different
genres but in this case I think it works
though but I can see how there are a few
things about this that
um are a little bit weird and I was
watching like a um like another review
of it with a reviewers that were
probably they weren't young but they
were like younger than me and the girl
had seen it before like lots of times
but she was showing it to her boyfriend
co-host whoever and he had never seen it
before but he ended up really really
digging it even though he said man this
movie is like so weird and like not at
all what I was expecting like given the
trailers so it is like the tone of it is
just kind of like very very strange and
I had forgotten I don't think I thought
it was strange in the 80s because there
were other movies like this but watching
it now I still really like it but I was
like wow this is like a way weirder
movie that I remembered you know what I
mean it's just so strange like the tone
of it yeah they did like four or five of
these around this period that's what I'm
thinking and so nobody really thought it
was all that odd back then I guess
another one it was kind of adjacent
would be like Death Becomes Her kind of
like this yeah a little wackier though
more clearly a comedy
yeah that that one I would pretty easily
that one's like a black comedy right it
has horror elements too but that's
mostly a black comedy and I will say
that I think Death Becomes Her is
largely more successful than this one
like it's just in terms of like what it
was trying to do and I love I [ __ ]
love Death Becomes Her I think we've
covered that before but yeah like that
one's much more obviously like a comedy
this one's a comedy too but I don't know
it has like some kind of strange tonal
things yeah something about this movie
wolf also seems to for me kind of
totally was kind of seemed like it was
linked in with
[ __ ] Dangerous Liaisons remember that
I love dangerously yeah although that is
not funny in this place
it's almost kind of like they were
targeting the same audience or if she
at least you know it's been a long time
since I've seen it but I remember that
movie kind of coming to mind watching
this Dangerous Liaisons is great yeah by
the way maybe because Michelle Pfeiffer
is that maybe maybe that's why right I
didn't realize that she's yeah Michelle
Pfeiffer is in it she's not like she's
kind of one of the main she's not one of
the main two characters because that's
John Malkovich and Glenn Close but she's
like one of them well there's also you
know it's rich people in palaces and
they're having all these weird Affairs
and it's all twisting around their face
Intrigue and stuff
and it's kind of like they're grubby
dirty people but but they're in these
real elevated settings
but really when you analyze them from a
moral stamp standpoint they're [ __ ]
degenerates you know and that's
basically like saying that's what a
witch is like a degenerate really you
know but they're in living in finery
yeah that's all Jack is or you know with
the [ __ ] the devil he's
kind of a
I won't call him a piece of [ __ ] but
just like a [ __ ] really just more
like an average Joe
the way he was acting we got butt hurt
and [ __ ] getting all vindictive
yeah that's the thing it's like At first
yeah I mean he's really just kind of an
average dude he's kind of like he's a
likable character even though he's
diabolical yeah
um okay but like I was waiting for you
to do that but um like at first you know
that he's manipulating each woman like
you know what I mean you know that he's
doing that it's very but they're
probably aware of it too but he's just
so good at it that they're just kind of
like all right I'll allow it but that's
the thing it's like it's almost kind of
like
even if he wasn't the devil he was just
like this really shitty dude that was
like really really awesome like at first
and was just kind of like oh you're so
cool and I'm gonna Elevate you and blah
blah blah and then like the second
you'll be like hey maybe we shouldn't
see each other anymore and then he gets
like [ __ ] he goes balls out and just
fills your bed full of snakes and gives
you like horrible hemorrhaging that'll
kill you and [ __ ] like that just that's
what I mean because just because the
dude's got a whole [ __ ] ton of money and
just because he's got a lot of skills
and charm doesn't mean a good person
right you know well he obviously isn't
because he's the devil right and then
the only the only way they can get him
to stop [ __ ] with them like and
particularly by Michelle Pfeiffer's
character Suki that's the only way they
can get her uh to stop hemorrhaging and
stop being in pain is to go and kiss his
ass again yeah um but then they kind of
like you know kind of conspire together
they're like yeah we'll go in there and
like pretend we're friends again and
then we'll [ __ ] him over yeah and all
his negativity and [ __ ] he was he was
feeling sorry for himself yeah I [ __ ]
butt hurt and [ __ ] ball depressed and
he got all [ __ ] his hair is all [ __ ]
up and he's like sitting around eating
ice cream and getting fat
so it's not like it's some kind of
demonic [ __ ] evil or anything it's
just more like you know like a regular
dude like a [ __ ] right yeah well see
that's to me that's like the funniest
aspect of the movie is that even though
he's clear he's supposed to be the devil
right yeah but he had all the same human
frailties and like you know the the
women told him hey we can't see you
anymore and like you said he's sitting
in front of the TV like eating frozen
galaja watching prices right yeah and
[ __ ] like that feeling sorry for himself
he can go out he's got all this money
you know and he could call and call
girls all [ __ ] day right and he's
worried about these three
random women right but see that's what
to me that was what was funny and I
think that's kind of like where some of
the source of the of the comedy was
coming from is that you wouldn't expect
someone as powerful as the devil to get
all hung up on these three women who
just called him and said hey we don't
want to see you anymore you wouldn't
expect that so like to me that's why it
was funny and then he just went off on
this big [ __ ] rant and he's in that
church like talking about women and like
God like did he do it to us on purpose
basically the movie ends he he has to go
back to hell but he can still you know
commune with the living and appear and
[ __ ] and he's trying to basically they
show kind of a [ __ ] basically he's
trying to get custody of the kids yeah
that's what he's trying to do he's
trying to get joint custody basically I
I think the implication was that the
reason that he could come back but he
only came back on the TV like to see the
babies
I think the reason I think they implied
that because there was a scene before
that where all three of the women were
sitting around with all the kids and
Susan Sarandon's character Jane she was
like thinking about him and shares like
hey like we can't think about him when
we're all together or we'll conjure him
back because that's how he came in the
first place and she's like oh well I
still want to think about him blah blah
but they try not to but I guess just
them doing that like all of three of
them thinking about it like for a for a
minute like he was able to come back on
the TV but maybe not in the flesh that
was the implication that I got and it
was fully manifest right because they
did because they cut it to like nipped
it in the bud because yeah he came there
because they conjured him even though
they weren't aware that that's what they
were doing because they didn't weren't
aware that they had powers at that point
but yeah the end it's really weird
because like the end of this gets really
really strange because up to now it's
been like I said kind of like a magical
there was a movie called Practical Magic
too but I kind of feel like
it wasn't as over the top as this one I
I saw it but I don't remember that much
about it and it was more chick flicky
but I kind of associate it with this one
because I think they came out right
around the same time I think that Sandra
Bullock and maybe Nicole Kidman in it I
want to say but it was a similar kind of
thing like middle-aged women or whatever
but if I remember correctly like finding
their power through witchcraft or
whatever but it was a lot more
Oprah friendly or whatever whereas this
one like I said kind of goes weird like
at the end like when they start doing
the spell like with the doll and he gets
like [ __ ] thrown all through the car
and like he then he ends up all [ __ ]
up looking and then he goes all giant
it's like this big claymation yeah like
Jack Nicholson thing like with a weird
mouth and then he turns into this little
I you know what I didn't realize what
that was when I was younger like when
they look out the window like after they
throw the wax doll Into the Fire and it
melts into little pieces I thought oh he
just shrunk down because they burned him
or whatever but when I was looking at it
when I watched the movie last night I
was like you know what I think that is I
think I think that's yeah or a mandrake
root okay I thought it was because it
has his face on it but it looked like a
mandrake and because you know it's like
the mandrake root they use that a lot in
witchcraft spells because it's a plant
but it looks kind of like a person sort
of if you squint
um so I thought it was a homunculus it
could have been that too it could have
been that too but it looked planty to me
I don't know I could totally be wrong
I'm Andre but it's that's kind of what I
the vibe that I got from likely it's a
mandrake but yeah so so yeah the the
[ __ ] gets like really really strange
toward the end but I mean I still really
really like this movie
um like you said I'm glad you brought up
Death Becomes Her because that's kind of
like a similar I mean it's not similar
similar but it's kind of the same kind
of vibe I guess
there's a little more friendly a little
more
fun it's a little more fun even yeah a
bunch of [ __ ] happens it is bad it's
still more fun this one is a little
darker it's more the same the tone is
more like wolf
yeah this one in Wolf are would be like
a good double feature because like I
said not only do both of them have Jack
Nicholson and Michelle Pfeiffer in the
dark but they're both kind of like yeah
like Yuppie fantasy yeah Romance
things with horror elements and comedy
yeah and it's like 25 or 30 30 chick
flick probably yeah with 30 [ __ ] yeah 30
chick flick there is a chick flick
element to it there is yeah but it's not
so much that dude couldn't like it all
right it's a good movie yeah it's a good
movie
um I didn't really like it that much but
I recognize it for what it is it's a
good movie it's just not you know
everything's art you know and it's just
it's just not my kind of movie let's
just put it that way yeah it's a good
movie but it's not really my kind of I
mean I love all the acting performances
in this I mean this the cast in this is
[ __ ] incredible I love the score
which was uh John Williams actually I
think he might have got an Oscar
nomination for this score I really like
the score of this I might have had it on
uh cassette tape now that I'm thinking
about it
um and I really still like um scenes
from this I think it's slightly slightly
too long like maybe some of the stuff
could have been uh trimmed out and maybe
I would have liked it if I'd gone like
slightly darker like the book although I
did kind of like I think one of the
things I didn't like about the book was
that it seemed like a little more
mean-spirited I didn't like that the
women like immediately were just kind of
like yeah let's like [ __ ] kill some
people I kind of like that they sort of
got finagled into it you know what I
mean more I don't know like maybe it was
just the writing of the book that I
didn't really like and it's been a long
time since I read it so I don't remember
but I remember liking the movie better
now I like this movie better than wolf
I like wolf too but yeah they are very
similar like in town same I really
didn't like either one of them yeah I
like but they're good moves yeah I like
this one probably I like this one a lot
more because I've seen this one a lot
more times like wolf I probably only
seen like two or three times because I
saw it one time and I was like oh that
was all right but this movie for some
reason like I really dug it like I just
really liked the three women's
interaction I really liked Jack
Nicholson just like [ __ ] Hamming it
up I mean he seemed like he was [ __ ]
born to play this role and he seems like
he's having a blast yeah he's great
watching this yeah it was supposed to be
Bill Murray first actually Bill Murray
was supposed to play the devil which
might have worked too and he he was
actually gonna do it but then like he
had to bow out at the last minute the
thing that I don't really like about
this movie and wolf also is that they
just try to the movie feels like it's
trying to be more than too many genres
at once that's kind of the way it feels
to me it's not what it's not in a clear
but you know some people will love that
it just depends on yeah it depends on
how it's done I like cross genre stuff
if it's done well sometimes it can be a
jarring I would have liked this to be a
straight up horror adventure with a lot
darker and a lot worse things should
have happened and then the whole kids
should have you know the babies should
have happened and they should have been
a little more Sinister I think they
should have had a very apocalyptic
ending like they were like you know like
the devil's taking over the Earth you
know I think it would have been a lot
better should have gone full Rosemary's
Baby
full Rosemary that'd be kind of cool
actually down there thinking about it
that's how I would have done it
but I understand that's not what that's
not the audience they were targeting
they were they were targeting an older
softer audience if you ask me
yeah I see what you're saying you know
what I mean they weren't targeting the
kids that were watching slasher movies
and watching [ __ ] uh uh the damn Omen
series or anything you know but I can't
like The Omen
yeah yeah that might have been that
might have been a good direction to go
that's I mean final Conflict type of
deal you know and [ __ ] the priests
are going damn the devil's [ __ ] got
all these kids how are we gonna stop
them you know yeah the kids have powers
and [ __ ]
yeah they should have had the little
kids with powers maybe they should have
had horns for all I know you know
something crazy
I'd have gone [ __ ] crazy well now
Rosemary's Baby they didn't show this in
the movie but in the book whereas Mary's
baby had horns yeah right they didn't
show that in the movie but that it is in
the book I think they should have been
clearly demonic yeah but they should
have been cool looking yeah you know
what I mean like good looking but
[ __ ] demons devil babies yeah it's a
little fake tails of [ __ ] yellow eyes
and stuff yeah I'm [ __ ] yeah baby
born with my debt with the devil
they're born with beards you know
yeah yeah yeah like like that little
cartoon of the devil yeah the little
like the little red the little red one
that have been super funny but yeah the
thing I mean the thing about they could
have actually made a sequel you know
with it with the three kids like growing
up or when they were kids or whatever
that would have been kind of funny but I
do kind of feel like yeah like when you
said Death Becomes Her
um which you know kind of similar but
that one was more clearly like I said in
some ways darker and in some ways more a
comedy but a black comedy whereas this
one had black comedy in it too but was
still kind of like tonally not as
consistent let's say that it didn't
bother me it still doesn't bother me but
I can see how if you're watching the
movie like you know I thought this was a
romantic comedy or I thought it was like
a witch fantasy or I thought or I
thought it was a horror movie and I'm
like it's all those things and more
um you know the target generation in 87
was Boomers so so a lot of the themes
and issues that they're
that that that are important to these
characters are Boomer issues you can
tell tell you know what I mean it's just
but like I said it it it's aged well
it's still an entertaining movie
it's not my kind of movie but it is a
good quality movie yeah I mean I
recommend it yeah you know it's just for
it's just not really my thing but it
might be your thing
for a fun like re-watching this one
actually in the 2000s like 2007 or
something like that they actually made a
series
um based on Witches of Eastwick but from
everything that I've heard like it
wasn't even like as dark or as fun as
the movie was yeah so they went even
more like in the Oprah friendly
Direction
um you know what I mean so which sounds
probably like I don't need to see it but
I still really do like this movie and
Oprah friendly yeah yeah well you know
what I mean yeah that like super super
womany kind of like that's not yes
that's what this movie and wolf always
gave me that that's a good way yeah that
that's that was nothing against women
obviously I am a woman you know what I
mean it was the when I saw that Oprah
crowd yeah it's like that 87 is who who
they were which I don't usually like but
I mean but I can see what you're saying
like this movie probably this movie was
kind of targeting that I mean John up
like as an author uh always kind of like
seemed like he was aiming for that
demographic too like not just women but
I mean just anybody in that kind of like
upper middle class yeah sort of thing
um I kind of feel like I've only read a
couple of his books but that's from just
from my understanding yeah the that
crowd has now matured into basically the
chicks on that on that program The View
that's that same generation if they were
targeting them back when they were in
their 30s
that's what this movie was targeting
yeah back when they were in their 30s
well like I said and that's girls my age
in the 80s were teenagers we're
teenagers um well they still responded
to this like in some ways well there was
crossover there was crossover yeah in
those days it was a contemporary movie
so it didn't really seem out of place
yeah the uh the movie I remember that
movies like this seemed real hip and
real elevated and real cool at the time
there's a because there was also movies
like Fatal Attraction that were kind of
targeted towards that same Boomer crowd
yeah they were good they had horror
elements to it and then those had then
that had spin-offs
so it was kind of like this
Yuppie kind of
what else was like that it's like classy
horror classy horror because you didn't
really see I mean in the 80s horror was
still seen as like a teenager genre
because it was like slasher movies and
[ __ ] like that so whenever you saw
something like Death Becomes Her or even
though I think that was a bit later or
like Witches of Eastwick which had
horror elements to it but had all these
really big stars and was like a big
Hollywood connection yeah [ __ ] like that
so I think that Pacific Heights wasn't
that that other one yeah yeah
that might have been like early 90s and
Fatal Attraction I think was 1990 also
but right around the same I mean yeah
just a couple years later yeah so I kind
of feel like yeah it's like horror
movies but for the older crowd yeah
because you couldn't like older people
back then nowadays the distinction has
disappeared but in the 80s you didn't
get like 35 40 year olds going to see
slasher movies but they would go see
something like this which is you know
has horror elements to it but you're
allowed to see it because it's like a
real movie now it is Generation
differences are harness pronounces what
they used to be right yeah there are
differences between gen Z and x and but
not it's not not as big anything like it
between like my grandparents generation
and Gen X
yeah it was like a mat that was like a
Chasm yeah and Boomers and Gen X was
[ __ ] there's a big difference there's
a big difference yeah yeah but even your
grandparents was like they're like from
another [ __ ] country yeah they were
like from China a thousand years ago
that's that was their thinking
yeah but it's like nowadays you know I
nowadays I watch videos by you know
people in their 20s and stuff like that
and they don't seem that different no
like their attitudes don't really seem
all that different so it's not like it
used to be but yeah it's this definitely
probably was you know targeted toward an
older crowd but I still really dug it
and uh you know it's actually on I
thought it was on HBO Max when I first
put it in the poll but then when I went
back it wasn't there but it's actually
on 2B for free so that's even better
because you can watch it without uh
without any uh you know paying for it
even though you got to watch commercials
but I mean if you guys have seen it like
let me know what you think about it um
like I said I used to love this movie
back in the old days so I was like kind
of happy to see it again and I feel I
still think it holds up
um it's not I don't love it quite as
much as back then but I still loved it
almost almost as much because I really
liked all the acting in it and all that
kind of stuff it's a good quality flick
it is yeah so uh let us know what you
think about it in the comments and
that'll do it for this movie
retrospective we'll see you guys again
on the next one bye
foreign